hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
ah
just checking in on you i'm just
checking in to see how you're doing
huh are you still quarantining
huh are you tangerine
what the [ __ ] are you doing what are we
doing we're waiting for the vaccine
huh i'm due to get it next month so you
guys can all look at me as a [ __ ]
test patient because i know i know what
the deal there's people out there i
ain't getting anything there [ __ ]
damn getting that [ __ ] dick
then i got other friends of mine going
dude they could shoot that thing into my
balls i don't give a [ __ ] i just want to
get back to my life
and then you got people in the middle
you know then i'm like
and then i like dude you can shoot at my
nuts they're they're they're the people
right you know those people right they
act like they're in the group but
they're not
they're really just in for themselves
the kind of [ __ ] people if the plane
crashed
you know and we all got to sit here and
and figure out how we're going to
survive
and everybody has a rationed amount of
food that person that you'd catch at
night
taking more than their share right
drinking baby formula
out for themselves i think there's gonna
there's there's a there's another skate
you got
everybody thinks that right now there's
just biden people and trump people
okay but there's other there's there's
another group of people
they're just they're just out for
themselves
okay they don't align they they they are
the the me party
meaning myself and i think what they're
going to do is they're going to be like
okay
i'm i believe in wearing masks
all right and i believe this virus is
real
and i believe that it's gone around the
world
because i still think the world is round
do flat earthers think this virus went
across the world
so anyways these people i think they're
going to sit there and be like listen
i know this thing's a bad [ __ ] deal
but i don't want to get this [ __ ]
vaccine because i don't trust the
government
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
let everybody else
get it okay and then it'll die out
and then i don't have to get it because
it won't be around anymore because no
one's gonna have it as long as i don't
have it
then that's what i'm gonna do
and then here's a [ __ ] sci-fi [ __ ]
scenario
what say what it what if you're right
and then everybody who gets the vaccine
[ __ ] dies
and then there's just this group of
people
the me people who don't get the vaccine
and now you have to try and all get
together
and rebuild this thing knowing
that you're all selfish [ __ ] and the
only thing that you can breed with
is another selfish [ __ ] and that your
kid
as much as you're going to love them
is going to be a selfish [ __ ] squared
you guys are all going to gather
together
right form a new selfish [ __ ] tribe
and then one day you're gonna see this
light at the top of a hill
right and you guys all start walking
towards it what is that
somebody lit a fire what is that and you
[ __ ] go
all the way up the hill and you realize
it's the biggest [ __ ]
compound mansion you've ever seen in
your life and you're hearing music
there's a pool the size of a [ __ ]
lake
everybody's inside singing and dancing
and all that
and all the [ __ ] me squared [ __ ]
walk into that house and come face to
face
with the people that created the vaccine
the [ __ ] music comes off
the illuminati people get up off that
virgin robot they just built
they face all of these selfish [ __ ]
and they go to war and the thing about
it is is the illuminati will win because
they are an organized group
where if either way they're selfish
[ __ ] too
i don't know
anyway sorry i'm having a weird week i'm
having a great
week and then um
you know i'm also having a bad week
because uh
you know i don't know i don't because of
social media took out
yet another friend of mine and i i just
don't know
i don't know it seems like now you can
literally make a statement
that is uninformed
it's just unbelievable it's it's unreal
i mean just
[ __ ] i don't get it
you know i don't agree with what i read
but i mean do i think that
then you should just everybody gets the
electric chair there's just no
like hey you know uh you might want to
read up on this a little bit more before
you compare this to that you know
it's just like flamethrower lit
done [ __ ] crazy man
[ __ ] crazy crazy goddamn times
um anyway
um as i just get a text you watching
this impeachment stuff
why would i watch that
that's like watching the nfl draft of
politics
if they impeach the guy or not they're
going to give you the results
what are you sitting there watching
getting like angry i had like the
greatest
[ __ ] week um
i really uh i i have gone back to
therapy
and there's two ways you can do therapy
you can go in there and you can just
blabber on and whine about your [ __ ]
life
or if you get a good therapist you can
listen to the information they give you
and then go out in the world and try and
uh apply it
which is uh i for i used to be the first
person now i've become the second person
and
um i had you know i sat down you know i
just
dealt with a couple of things this week
and uh i feel a lot better and i feel a
lot less angry
which is uh it is going to pay dividends
um with my home life so
i don't know i don't mean to be all
billy feels here man but uh
i feel a lot better i feel you know i
kind of feel like why did it take me 30
years to undo
20 years of [ __ ] um
but i guess that's that's how it is
that's how it is so
i haven't been doing [ __ ] other than
that trying to work on myself
and um
what did i do i don't know sorry guys
i'm i'm like um there's a number of
[ __ ] things
that are just really bothering me right
now about just this whole
lionizing of like regular
[ __ ] people as like these saints and
it's just like everybody's a human being
everybody
makes mistakes everybody is flawed
and uh i i just don't understand this
just [ __ ]
i don't know i don't want to even talk
about this [ __ ] because it's not worth
it man don't [ __ ] talk about it what
are you going to do
what what the [ __ ] anyways let's talk
hockey everybody hey anybody watch that
bruins rangers game last night
whoa um jesus christ the rangers look
[ __ ] great i
no team this year has jumped on the
bruins the way the rangers did last
night
and i don't know how many posts and
crossbars they [ __ ] hit
but there was a period during that game
it sounded like somebody was there was a
[ __ ] wind chime or something going on
but uh the bruins as always just tuka
ross
was just unfucking believable he's the
only reason why
the game wasn't like five to one after
uh two periods
um we went down one nothing
and then chris wagner had a [ __ ]
shorty our power play
kill is [ __ ] incredible we got
another short-handed goal
made it 1-1 right another short-handed
goal this season i mean so we
made it 1-1 then we went up 2-1
um with debrusk with the sanderson to
bobby or feed from behind the net
uh to oh it was to bjork right andres
bjork
to make it 2-1 then the rangers came
back which was not surprising the way
that they were playing like i said they
played great
and um made it 2-2 we went into overtime
and rangers came down charlie mack back
on defense they tried a little saucer
pass didn't put enough mustard on it
charlie knocked it down mid-air
nice [ __ ] pass off the boards to a
streaking brad marshawn
who once again once again
gets the winner in overtime his 16th
career over time he's won so many games
in overtime
he doesn't even go nuts he's just like
yeah this is what i do
this is just what i do i end the game he
almost ended the game like a minute
before
completely undressed this defenseman if
the goalie didn't i think the defenseman
jumped in the way of the puck
an amazing game but i'm really
interested to see this next game friday
against the rangers because i want to
see
if that was just an inspired effort or
if that's how they are if that's how
they are
um i would say that the the
rangers and the capitals so far this
season are
like it's looking like they're going to
be the biggest problems in um
for us in the playoffs but i don't know
who else i haven't been watching a lot
of the canada hockey i
i watched some highlights today of uh
the maple leafs beat the habs of course
i'm happy about that but the [ __ ]
canadians look great but just the way
we're just sort of quarantined now where
we're just sort of playing everybody's
playing sort of the same six or eight
teams
um i haven't really looked at the
standings but somebody's got to be in
like a soft
division and it's gonna have pumped up
numbers and then i think somebody else
is gonna be in a harder one you're not
gonna think they're that good because of
their record
and uh it'll all be sorted out in the
playoffs but uh
i've been loving that i've been loving
the watching the bruins as much as i've
been struggling watching the celtics on
that west coast
swing they had where they uh beat the
warriors lost to the kings
beat the clippers then lost back-to-back
sons and uh to utah so i think that what
did they go like uh
was it one and oh one and one two and
one
two two and three they went two and
three holy [ __ ]
utah jazz before the game they were like
yeah these guys uh
these guys are great at shooting
three-pointers right and jaylen rose
went out in the first three possessions
of celtics he hit three three pointers
had nine points and i was like all right
here we go and then utah i don't know
just the whole game they were up like
six eight points and then we started to
close it
then they got up by like 10 and we
started coming back and then with like
four minutes less
left this kid donovan mitchell just took
over the [ __ ] game and there was
nothing we could do about
it and he put us out of our misery
quickly
um yeah i also like that
rudy gobert guy uh jordan clarkson it
was another guy who was
fun to watch it wasn't fun that they
were killing my own [ __ ] team that
kid devin booker was fun to watch too in
the suns but jesus christ
um i don't know we shall see
we shall see um where that ends up going
but uh i already had a good day man
as far as like i took my daughter to
school
and uh she's like dad i want to listen
to the song
right so i downloaded that song by 38
special
uh hold on loosely
right fun song to play on guitar
and um
i've been playing it you know a couple
days in a row so now she likes it and
she actually said 38 special today
and then after i played it she said ac
dc
she goes ac dc what that mean because
she knows it's letters like she thinks
it spells a word
and uh i was like it means they're the
greatest rock and roll band of all time
in my opinion
so she listened to hold on loosely and
back in black which i think is great
because when she rides with my my wife
she gets a totally different playlist so
i think she's gonna have a nice
well-rounded uh music background
and um and then she said something that
was
uh really made me feel
feel great like she uh i think she kind
of has a crush on one of the little boys
and she's like i just love him because
he's a boy
and he can he can speak french like you
know somebody else in the class or
something like that and then she then
the greatest thing ever she goes
and he's nice like my mommy and daddy
and i was like oh my god because you
always hear that
that you know if
your daughter you as a father you how
much you have to be there for your
daughter
because if you're an [ __ ] she's going
to go date [ __ ] so
so far so good she's four years old
and she likes a nice kid because
he's nice like her mommy and daddy and
uh
i told my wife that and we were just
like we high five like all right
you know we're in the first quarter um
oh god that's scary
18 divide by four
let's see goes in there four
with two left over so like
at four and a half four and a half
almost through the first quarter
of raising my kid already that's how
fast it goes holy [ __ ]
yeah four and a half years old because
at nine you're at half time
right 18 they graduate
high school and then go off to college
and uh jesus that's gotta be
just did i give the person all the
information
they need you know what i always thought
about with stuff like that is when i got
my pilot's license i always wanted to
ask an instructor like
you know when they sign you off to solo
it's like
you know the level of of
confidence they have to have in you
because they they don't want that on
their record they obviously don't want
to see you
kill yourself or yourself and somebody
else
um speaking of which um
i soloed the uh cadbury g2 for the first
time
um it was a low visibility day so i
didn't go fly out i just stayed at the
airport i just flew the pattern
which is basically like a big rectangle
um all right you guys will learn a
little aviation [ __ ] so like when you
take off you know clear for takeoff uh
runway eight right close traffic
means you would take off runway eight
and those are also degrees on the
compass
is why runways have numbers and then
taxiways have leather
letters if you go to an airport right
so that's and that's the heading you're
flying
you're flying towards like zero eight
which would be basically north slightly
northeast
you're flying that heading and then
right close traffic which means you'd
fly out
and then you make a right turn that's
your crosswind turn and then your
downwind turn
is you're going now parallel to the
runway you just took off from
going the opposite direction then you
turn base
and then you turn final so you can just
fly that pattern
right and as you're doing it at any
point the tower could then say make left
traffic
the winds could change they could tell
you to go the other way all of that [ __ ]
so you just stay there
it was like four miles visibility and i
was like literally right there at the
airport so
um i wasn't worried about that aspect of
it it's like now i have to land
on um a helipad
i have a little four-wheeler that tows
the um
the helicopter out so the first my first
lift lift off and
and off the pad and landing on it when i
was with my instructor
all you're doing is looking at the
four-wheeler going don't hit that
do not hit that whatever you do don't
hit it it's like greg brady trying to
beat marsha gotta beat marsha
got to get closer than a quarter of an
inch and he [ __ ] knocks the egg off
the [ __ ] orange cone
for a 50 year old reference there um but
what you really want to do is you want
to look beyond you just want to look
long and just try to hold a hover and
then gradually set down or lift
up and um so anyway i
did the pattern for about 35 minutes and
um
had to go pick up my kid at school so i
i uh
on the next one i was just did my radio
call and asked for a full stop
so then they tell you you know and then
they give you the taxi way to exit
you know cleared for land one two
exit delta right so i do that and then
i'm just sitting there
and my instructor was in a helicopter
that was
like still on the ground behind me they
hadn't even started it up yet
and uh it was pretty cool he filmed me
coming in and landing on the pad
and i knew he was watching too so all my
years of doing stand-up and having big
industry people watching me
or you know doing dave letterman or the
apollo or any of those
high-pressure gigs taping a special i i
was like okay go to that headspace and i
was just like all right just chill look
long
and i went in and uh i set it down nice
a little bit
like harder than i wanted to but i was
just kind of like i'm still getting used
to where the skids are
because the thing sits lower than what i
used to fly so i always feel like okay
why am i not touching the ground so then
um it came down ended up being really
nice
and i was [ __ ] over the moon i was so
excited
and um yes and i think i'm going to
start picking up my instrument training
again because now i i'm
got my skill level back up to where it
needs to be because i didn't fly a lot
during the beginning
of the pandemic because everybody was
shut down and everything and i'm
super like always making sure
it's like i will literally do 50 [ __ ]
auto rotations before i'll
go out and solo
better safe than sorry all right so
here's some tears some stuff here um
comedy central is going to be airing the
patrice o'neill documentary
on february 19th okay that's the debut
now i'm very excited about this but i
got
information that on the 19th they're
going to be showing
like that's like an edited version of it
they're taking out 14 minutes because
they want to show an episode
of the office after it okay it's a
business
i get it there's commercials there's all
of this type of stuff so just letting
you know
that you're going to be seeing an
abridged version of it
um the
the real version i guess the next time
they show it will show
the complete version of it
so um i'm a little bummed out because
it's the debut and i'm a little confused
as to why it's going down like that but
i also understand that it is a business
and there's all of this competition and
streaming and all of that and they just
they got to do what they got to do
whatever so um
but they are gonna air the complete
version of it comedy central is and
thank god for them because they
are going to show this so i'm very happy
to be in business with them
but business is still business so i'm
just letting you know what's up
but i'm very excited mike bonfigulo
absolutely
killed it um and then all
patrice's friends you know norton voss
kev keith um colin quinn
the whole all of his peeps are in it
um it's gonna be great and i hope you
guys uh
enjoy it i hope you tune in and watch it
and you tell people that have never
heard
of patrice o'neill to uh sit down and
watch it i would really really
appreciate it i'm
telling you guys i need you on this one
all right
this is an all things comedy produced um
documentary um
um comedy central and vaughn
monte carlo uh patrice's girlfriend
put it together and then they came to us
to produce it and then mike bonfiglio
signed on and once we got him to sign on
the whole thing went through
you know patrice's mom george is in it i
mean this is this one is
is the real deal um the people closest
to him are in this thing and
i know there's been some other people
fans have put some things together but
this one goes
deeper than all of that thank god and uh
i hope we did the big man
justice all right that is all let me
read some um
let me read some uh uh advertising here
oh look who it is oh
max oh max how could you
uh living with chronic pain is the worst
it's more than a feeling
um i was actually saying that to the 38
special
it's more than a feeling sorry uh of
discomfort
it can affect your whole life many of my
listeners probably have some type of
pain that has prevented them from
relaxing
and sleeping or stopped them from
exercising perhaps it's been going on
for a few weeks now and hasn't improved
with any of the treatments they've tried
uh
enter okay podcast host to provide
experience of recent pain
uh i've actually been feeling pretty
good because i've been using omax
[Laughter]
my my last little rotator cuff that was
[ __ ] bugging me i put it on it
on my back on my shoulder blade it's
been feeling great
so i don't have any i don't have any
pain right now other than watching the
celtics lose two in a row
um enter omax health if you're looking
to get rid of nagging muscle and joint
pain
immediately while providing long-lasting
recovery then you need to try
the natural breakthrough pain relief
solution cryo-freeze
cbd roll-on i love that it's a roll-on
developed by omax health oh
max what did you do this time this
non-prescription
triple action pain relief roll-ons is
specially formulated to block pain
receptors
reduce inflammation and improve muscle
and joint flexibility
the best part is this 100 natural cbd
powered remedy works its magic
within 10 minutes of application and
relief lasts up to eight hours
much longer than the over-the-counter
products
oh max health is offering my listeners
off a bottle of cryo-free cbd pain
relief roll on it
you got to do this [ __ ] man have you got
pain in your hands all that stuff a
buddy of mine you know rode motorcycles
for a long time and his hands from you
know
i don't know doing whatever the [ __ ] you
do shifting and all that just bugged him
and he he slapped it on there and he
feels great um
oh max you shouldn't have omax health is
offering might already said that part
this discount only applies to wars
products toward
okay this discount also not only this
discount
also applies towards any product
site-wide just go to
omaxhealth.com today and enter bur enter
the code bird that that is omax omax
health.com and enter bur to get 20
off cryofreeze site wide
now doesn't that feel like that should
be the end of the read for some reason
they keep going they oversell it
anyone from athletes to grandma josie
can benefit from we got it it's [ __ ]
great i'm an old [ __ ] it worked on me
all right stitch fix
everybody stitch fix
um online shopping can be daunting
look at all the options uh you can never
know you never know if things will fit
do i look bad in this returns are
difficult who do i call
and you don't even know what's what
store to start with
this season this season let stitch fix
to
uh do all the hard work i think this is
leftover holiday
this season what the oh [ __ ] it's
valentine's day i haven't got my wife
[ __ ] i think i need to get on stitch fix
um as the days get longer and the
weather gets colder it may be time to
take a look
at your winter wardrobe if you want to
make a change this season stitch fix can
help you choose
new pieces you love oh they're talking
about the winter season
if your if your go-to outfit in 2020 has
become sweatshirts or yoga pants
you may be feeling like you're in a
style rut let stitch fix
help you feel excited about what you're
wearing uh
did you just look over your current cold
weather wardrobe options
and get a chill it is time to ditch that
old sweater and upgrade that jacket a
stitch
personal stylist can help you pick new
pieces that are timeless
stitch is there such a thing as this
timeless ski pocket
stitch fix offers clothing hand selected
by
expert stylist for your unique size
style and budget
every piece is chosen for your fit and
your life and it's the easy solution
to finding what makes you look and feel
your best try on pieces at home before
you buy
keep your favorite and send best send
back the rest stitch fix
has free shipping easy returns and
exchanges and a prepaid
return envelope is included uh there's
no subscription required try stitch fix
once or set up automatic deliveries
you'll pay just 20
a 20 styling fee for each box which gets
credited towards pieces you keep
and there's no hidden fees ever stitch
fix has styles and clothing to fit any
occasion for women men and kids
they ship all over the u.s and available
in the uk as well get started today at
stitchfitch.com
mmp and you'll get 25 percent off when
you keep
everything in your fix that's
stitchfix.com
mmp for 25 off when you keep everything
in your fix
stitchfix.com mmp
all right there we go and as always
during these cold winter months
all right don't forget to get some of uh
tim herb alexander
his hard cider um
it's the perfect [ __ ] drink
herbscider.com
during these cold winter months i know
you guys are getting crushed by the snow
back there imagine okay you're done
shoveling
you're coming into your little hot stove
there and you got a little bit of herb
cider there
you know a nice [ __ ] oh man that
makes me want to go skiing
that's my favorite thing about skiing
other than skiing back in the day when i
did it before i realized i was gonna
blow up both my [ __ ] knees
um or bend my thumb backs to my wrists
um
was that beer remember you you always
thought you had one more run in you and
then you just
fell down the [ __ ] hill your [ __ ]
legs were like spaghetti
um my favorite thing was you'd go in
and then you'd just get the [ __ ] that
[ __ ] ice cold beer you know
your face all red they always had some
big fire going on in the middle
and uh of course you never could find a
place to [ __ ] sit and there was also
a bunch of rich [ __ ] in there but other
than that
you know it was fun you know um you
could do that in your house
all right crank up your gas [ __ ]
fireplace and have a little bit of herb
cider at herbscider.com
h-e-r-b-s-c-i-d-e-r
dot com um all righty
all right what else did i want to talk
about how much more time do i got left
here on the podcast before i have to get
back to nine million other things
um that i have to do um
oh you know what i actually had a social
distance
uh thing yesterday that i went to i went
i was like three other comedians that
i've known since way back in the day
it's [ __ ] hilarious we're all sitting
like i don't know do you watch the uh
the nba thing now where they got shaq is
like [ __ ] 9 000 feet away and then
there's the white dude
and then the chick and then the other
guy and they're all just like
i don't know where's charles barkley
been lately
i haven't seen him on that thing i don't
know wait a minute let me look up jesus
christ you can't even keep up the people
that get in trouble now
charles barkley let's see what comes up
come on charles hang in there buddy
all right nothing but his stats in
wikipedia okay the man's still in the
game
whoo it was [ __ ] hilarious i guess
shaq went up with i saw this really
[ __ ] hilarious interview where he was
interviewing that kid donovan mitchell
on the utah jazz and he's just like
donovan
this is jack he's like hey shaq what's
up he's like
i don't think you have what it takes to
go to the next level
and he's like okay what do you think
about that he's like yeah whatever man
you know and then you know he has this
big game against the celtics and then
shaq took credit he's like you're
welcome i've always motivated people
and then somebody posts the stats going
like he's been playing like this all
year
now i love shaq i hope he's not becoming
a grumpy old man
hating on the young players you know who
knows
i don't know what but i don't know [ __ ]
about the nba but i just thought it was
funny he's like my whole career
i have been a motivator and a leader
um by insulting people and saying that
they suck
um so they'll prove me wrong i
understand that though
that is the power what is that reverse
psychology
maybe that's what it is maybe that's a
two-point reversal
um i don't know anyway that is the
thursday afternoon podcast
uh i don't know what to say here just
listen to the music and then we have
another bonus half hour of material
from a uh bonus half hour episode from a
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast
from um i don't know a few years ago i
think that's how we do it the great
andrew thermalist picks out the music so
uh look him up follow him on twitter and
uh he'll get back to you if you like the
music and they'll
you know want to know what it is all
right that's it have a great weekend you
[ __ ] and i will talk to you later go
bruins go celtics
[Music]
i
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
february 11th 2013.
um how are you how's it going how's your
week going so far
uh you know i just looked across my room
and i saw an object that reminded me of
one of my many failures this week
i was in a rush to leave my house and uh
i was taking my truck because i was
finally going to get the brakes done
i bought a kit to switch my [ __ ]
um i got drum brakes on my old truck
and as much as i wanted to keep the
truck as original as possible just the
way people text and drive
out here and there's so many people i
just know that if i ever hit somebody
with the front end of that beautiful
truck that
you know i'm never gonna be able to
replace the parts so i'm like i gotta do
this [ __ ] all right
so uh christopher titus
very talented christopher titus uh he's
into all of that [ __ ] so he tells me go
out and go buy a kit
we'll drive it over to my place and
we'll [ __ ] slap this thing on
it's gonna take no more than four hours
bing bang boom everything's [ __ ] done
right
so i'm all excited i bought this kit by
the way in july
of last year and it's just been sitting
in my office
i've been using it like just you know
putting my legs up on it
because um because life goes by that
fast when you're as
old as i am next week yeah next week
next week next thing you know you've
[ __ ] had the thing for like six
months
so finally we set a date we're like all
right let's [ __ ] let's do it
was it wednesday we were gonna do it and
uh you know i'm [ __ ] nervous
i don't know what i'm doing so anyways i
got to move the prius out of the way
so i moved that out of the [ __ ] way
and i got the hazard lights on you know
because it's the day where the [ __ ]
come around they give people parking
tickets so i bring the truck up right i
got the [ __ ] choke out
bringing up the [ __ ] thing right
and in my haste bringing the [ __ ] car
back i
i left the hazard lights on
so after we were done with the job i
came home and uh my [ __ ]
the [ __ ] car was dead and i'm like no
big deal
i know how to jump start this [ __ ]
hybrid i know how to do it
i watched the aaa guy do it and i went
out and i bought one of those
self-contained
battery pack [ __ ] things open the
hood
cute little hood that it is i opened the
little battery pack i took the little
red thing off and i can't [ __ ] figure
out how to clip it on i tried to clip it
on the bolt rather than that metal tab
it didn't matter anyways because my
thing wasn't [ __ ] charged and i had
to call
aaa to have my car jumped do you realize
the level of of like how emasculating
that is
have somebody come over you know have
somebody teach you how to convert your
brakes okay that that's understandable
all right that's that's some next level
[ __ ]
right it's [ __ ] jumper cables
that was the old was the worst when the
guy showed up i should have come out of
the house in a dress
um just a defeated [ __ ] man but i i
bit the bullet i was like yeah i can't
figure out how to do it
he explained it my thing didn't work
anyways and now i can't find the cord
to charge the [ __ ] thing so there
there it sits
here it sits actually i just kind of
slam that whole thing together reality
is
it took us two and a half days to get
the [ __ ] brakes on because uh the
back plates that you stick the rotors on
once mark left the other one was marked
right and we put them on
we know the difference between left and
right and
titus kept going is it me or does it
look like it's kind of like
torquing in like it's bent what the you
know and i'm looking at it like i know
what's going on
oh you know it looks pretty good to me
right you know put the [ __ ] things on
it's rubbing if you turn too far
to the left or the right you know
the calipers are going to hit the
springs the [ __ ] brake lines weren't
long enough the whole goddamn kit
so finally we get these people on the
phone i'm not going to say who they were
but i would finally get them on the
phone and they were like oh yeah we had
a batch of them
uh went out and uh they weren't labeled
right
i got to tell you something titus and
one of the most eloquent [ __ ]
ass rippings you've ever seen in your
life never raised his voice
never cursed i think he said one f-bomb
but it was a throwaway
because he was like you know i've been
i'm been [ __ ] here for three days
like one of those things not saying
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] but other than
that never cursed
and he just basically went right down
the line like
and so you knew these were labeled wrong
and you didn't call anybody
this these this is a safety issue and
the guy
at first would not admit any wrongdoing
to the point it was hilarious
he wouldn't admit any wrongdoing at one
point i swear to god he goes well did
you look at the picture
now in defense of them the picture was
right but the picture was like the size
of maybe three postage stamps and it was
in black and white
and it was very confusing because you
couldn't quite see it but
you kind of could but it was written
clear as day
left and right so what are you gonna go
with what i can barely see
or what i can clearly read that's what
we went with
and uh oh my god and then we finally got
that out of them and then we [ __ ]
switched them and then it worked
like a dream but the great thing was
was trying to figure it out we put them
on and take took them off like
i think at least three times so
i kind of got three like um
it's almost like i did three three break
jobs i got like that level of experience
and i gotta tell you it was the [ __ ]
coolest thing ever
to finally do something like that to see
how it all goes together it was
absolutely uh
fascinating and um
i don't know titus is the [ __ ] because
he would not
he could have just slapped it on and hey
go take it to your mechanic i don't know
what the [ __ ] going on he was
determined to get this thing
on correctly and he did and when he
found out it was messed up
he went to bat for me and he so
eloquently read these guys
that they actually gave me a credit on
the kit so it didn't cost me a [ __ ]
dime
how great is that and then we said ah
you guys are all right now we're gonna
send him some dvds and it's all a wash
so i finally that was was so three two
and a half days of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then i finally dude i
went to autozone like [ __ ] nine times
and every time i came into autozone i
was a little more tired and a little
more dirty
[Music]
nothing i was thinking
how enjoyable it would have been
had the whole thing gone together i
won't probably want to learn nearly as
much
but just uh
you know like when you watch those
youtube videos like eric the car guy and
he's just [ __ ] it's just this goes
here and this goes here you take that
off put this on and put this thing back
on and just
it just goes so [ __ ] smoothly
and uh that was not the case on this
thing but when we finally got it all
together
um it was tremendous and i'm i'm psyched
now but this is how much of a
sentimental fool i am i'm
i'm keeping the old drum breaks and i
bought the tools to be able to put it
back together just because i don't want
to leave it
i want to learn how to do it then i also
don't want to just leave all the springs
and [ __ ]
laying around in the garage you know
kicking them around and [ __ ] you know
how long can you really leave that [ __ ]
around before something [ __ ] happens
and then you lose it forever
so there you go how'd you like that that
was my uh fixing the brake story
so i now have i now have uh
uh uh disc brakes and i put one of the
rotors on with the caliper
and all of that and uh i was beyond uh
beyond psyched although it does have a
friend it does help to have a friend
who's basically a master [ __ ]
mechanic who has all the goddamn tools
uh who's getting who i should have been
over there with a [ __ ] nurse's outfit
on i was just handing them [ __ ]
but whatever i got dirty
[Laughter]
um so anyways i i have no idea
what is uh going on in the world right
now because uh
for some reason i've decided to do like
10 do-it-yourself [ __ ] projects
and uh i'm painting my living room so
i and i don't know it's a it's a
[ __ ] it's a pain in the ass it's
easy but it's a pain in the ass and
i need to tape everything up and i
haven't watched tv for like the last two
days so i know it snowed in boston
uh that blizzard what the [ __ ] are they
calling it nokia
nardia what the hell is it here
nemo nimoy nemo
blizzard nemo i guess they're going to
name
snow storms now you know i don't need to
get into that enough comedians have made
fun of how much they overhyped these
things this looks
like it was actually a decent amount of
snow but in the end even if you have
like
you know [ __ ]
let's say there's three feet of snow
you know i mean what is what is that up
to let's say two feet of snow two feet
of snow is that even up to your knees
if you're an average size adult
like what is gonna you can go 30 days i
think i've said this before in the
podcast you can go 30 [ __ ] days
without food
maybe more than that the big thing is
water
all right snow right there it's a nice
[ __ ] handful of cold water stick it
in your mouth
and just relax let it melt you're going
to be fine you're not going to die
some guy on youtube made this hilarious
video of just screaming i have to get uh
i have to get bread and milk i think
it's already got 2 million hits
it's it's the funniest [ __ ] thing why
do you have to get
bread and milk i don't
i i guess if i was old i would be
nervous
but only if if like you know if the heat
went out then that's the only way i
would be nervous but other than that
it's just [ __ ] snow
you're gonna get the day off you can go
sledding build a snowman
just put on a [ __ ] scarf you [ __ ]
it's easy for me to say right i'm out
here in [ __ ] los
angeles i gotta tell you though you know
it's been a while since i've been in
snow and i saw some of the pictures my
my buddy sent me this going look at what
the [ __ ] i'm dealing with and that
actually looked awesome to me
you know snow's fun to visit but you
don't want to live in it
when it first comes down it's beautiful
and then once it starts being dirty and
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] you just get tired
there's less parking spots
everybody down and south is shoveling
out their cars
putting a [ __ ] trash barrel there
some yup he doesn't know the rules
pulls in his little [ __ ] pujo and he
never sees it again
um at least that's how i heard it works
there uh this is the uh monday morning
podcast uh what am i gonna do here
well you know what else i missed today i
didn't realize the bruins i know that
their game against tampa bay got
canceled and i didn't realize that they
played
the buffalo sabres which has become a
big rivalry
and i know a lot of you guys don't like
hockey especially the douche who had to
write me on twitter to let me know that
he tried to watch
hockey didn't enjoy it it literally
wrote yawn
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know
i just said you know if you it's a great
sport watch bruins montreal if you want
to try to get into
do i really need your [ __ ] like do
you think the nhl get well maybe they
give a [ __ ] maybe they want your money
you know write down why are you writing
me like i'm the goddamn commissioner
anyways why do i read them i don't know
why i re i should just not read them
um so anyways people hate [ __ ]
sabers they hate lou cheech because he
ran over their goalie
last year and it hurt the guy granted it
was a douche move but you know
he was frustrated he had a breakout he
couldn't settle down the puck and old
[ __ ]
old big eyes came out of the net came
out a little too far
you know when he ran him over you're
right you're right to be mad at him but
can you please stop
asking why lucich won't fight john scott
why do you get john scott is like 6 8
270. he's a [ __ ]
goon he can barely skate
why why would you have an all-star fight
that guy
risk getting hurt and then sit in the
box that's why he's not fighting him
there's no way ownership is gonna let
that guy fight
all right and all lucicha's is a [ __ ]
million dollar piece of meat
to the ownership you know what i mean so
they're not gonna have him go out there
and go fight that big [ __ ]
sasquatch
he shouldn't even go out there on skates
you should just walk out there with like
work boots on
i don't know he probably can play they
don't allow him to but i hate when
people say that [ __ ]
they pick like the best guy in your team
and they're like yeah he's too much of a
[ __ ] to fight our toothless [ __ ] yeah
that's a good switch off that's a good
trade-off let's have one of our best
guys
sit down for five minutes and all you
lose is some [ __ ]
goddamn gorilla i get it buffalo you're
upset
okay you want to see lou cheech get
pounded
i understand you're probably logic is
well [ __ ] what about saucer eyes
there
he wasn't exactly a tough target
um yeah maybe he deserves it i don't
know i feel bad for people in buffalo
you know what i mean that's just
that's i've been there as a sports fan
fortunately they let me up off the mat
over the last 10 years you know i'm
rooting for you guys
you know i know what people say to you
i know exactly what the [ __ ] i dealt
with that bucky dent
1918 all that [ __ ] horseshit
the [ __ ] curse with the canadians
back when they dominated us
25 [ __ ] years ago whatever the hell
it was unless you're dan shaughnessy
every time he lose to him he starts
the curse is back noodle-headed [ __ ]
um i know what you're going through i
know people say wide right they say
brett hull
they say why do you play sports why
don't you just stick to making
appetizers
you already came up with buffalo wings
is there something else you guys can
come up with that we can enjoy eating
while we watch
our teams win championships i realize
they say holy county [ __ ] to
and it eats away at you after a while
it's awful
you know i i don't i don't have any
animosity
towards any fans who go through [ __ ]
like that haven't gone through it myself
i only wish it on uh you know who i wish
it on
i don't need to get into that [ __ ]
anymore
um hey take a kobe stop passing the ball
you guys are losing again huh did you
figure it out laker fans
or did you just figured out a new way to
compliment kobe bryant
unbelievable do you know like last week
out here uh kobe for like three games in
a row actually passed the ball for the
first time in his career he actually was
passing the ball on a regular basis
and i know a lot of people are going to
say because they wrote to me he's good 5
000 careers just
muggsy bogues has over six thousand in
like three less seasons
okay the motherfucker's not passing the
ball
everybody who plays with them is not
lying they're not making up [ __ ]
all right guy finally passes the ball
and plays the team game [ __ ] the
lakers night and day all of a sudden
there is
this this team that's winning and the
laker fans think
oh oh that was the problem
kobe was the [ __ ] problem no they
immediately
dropped to their knees and blow them
again it's a new facet to his game
they started calling him magic bryant
kobe johnson i just i
i've never seen i i just don't
understand
i'm not saying the guy individually
once again this it's the peyton manning
thing all over again
individually phenomenal it's not even
that's not even peyton manning
i can't even bring him up ah christ i'm
rambling let's do uh
can you tell i got a zillion [ __ ]
things in my mind this this podcast is
more [ __ ] [ __ ] than usual
all right anyways plowing ahead here
let's uh
what's today the 11th oh my god
valentine's day is only three days away
what are you gonna do how many guys out
there are actually sitting around
and you haven't you haven't uh you
haven't stepped up yet you don't know
what you're going to do
you want it you want to step in the
right direction proflowers.com
all right impress her friends her
friends are going to ask you so what did
you get her for valentine's day what did
you get her and you'd be like a big
bouquet of flowers
or a big bouquet however the hell you
say it impress your woman
and her friends it's probably even more
important to impress her friends send
her flowers from pro flowers yeah get
her the best kind with the biggest damn
vase
shut all her friends up and she'll be
happy for a couple of days
right uh one dozen romantic rainbow
roses and a free glass
vase from my friends at proflowers.com
for just
19.99 20 bucks 20 bucks you're already
getting kisses
and for my listeners double the roses
for just 9.99 more
uh you just need my code bur b-u-r-r
when you order
um what the hell is this
please use this time to tell your
listeners about your personal experience
how did the flowers look how did they
smell how did your recipients
oh okay i got this i guess i was
supposed to read that before
um you know what last year they said
some to my
mother and she loved them
called me up left me a great message and
i saved it for six months
that's how happy she was that's how
wonderful the message is the the message
she was that she left do you understand
what i'm saying here people you can't go
wrong and only cost you 20 bucks
here's the only way to get this amazing
valentine's day deal you call 1-800 pro
flowers and mention burr b-u-r-r
or go to theproflowers.com or go to
proflowers.com click on the mic
click on the microphone in the top right
hand corner
and type in bur b u r r that's
proflowers.com
click on the microphone and type in burb
b you are our
order today and um and get on with your
wonderful day hey
ladies you know what's to stop you this
year from get your guy oh man you should
do that
get him four dozen roses just embarrass
the hell out of him send it down to the
job site
uh proflowers.com do it today
all right the next one here let's get
through this here what do we got what do
we got um
oh here we go stamps.com everybody if
you never want to go to the post office
again but you want to be able to do
everything that you can do within the
post office all you have to do
is just sign up at stamps.comstamps.com
everything you do at the post office you
can do right from your desk
buy and print us postage for any letter
or package using your own computer and
printer
stamps.com will send you a digital scale
calculates the exact amount of postage
you need for any class of mail
then just hand your mail to the mailman
drop it in the mailbox or even schedule
a free package pick up using stamps.com
you'll never have to deal with bad
weather again to send out letters and
packages i use stamps.com to send out
all my dvds to my road gigs
i've never had a problem i weigh it i
get the figure
it prints it out i slap it on i go to
the gig and magically they're there
right now use my last name burr burr for
this special offer no risk trial plus
bonus offer includes the digital scale
and up to 55 dollars
in free postage don't wait go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page and type in
burr burr that's stamps.com
enter bur burr alrighty
moving on
yeah so i missed the game yeah i missed
the game today and i i saw campbell
jump that guy in the sabers he got he uh
he didn't come out too well in that one
i love how the guy in the state was like
looking the ref like i don't want to
fight
all right what does what does
um all right enough with the sports talk
okay i need to appease the ladies and
the nerds out there
oh here's one for you um this weekend i
actually took a
night off from stand-up comedy and i
went out to uh
indio california i can't remember the
name of the casino
i saw don rickles i had to do it man i i
was like i always see these guys
underrated going to a casino and seeing
a legend
he was amazing and tony orlando tie a
yellow ribbon
he destroyed in front of him i didn't
realize how many hits that guy had
you know i went with bartnik and i was
just going like i think this guy's gonna
open with ty a yellow ribbon
he's gonna close with it and he's gonna
uh
he's gonna play it again in the middle
and he came right out of the gate
tie a yellow ribbon and in my world i'm
like this guy's out of hit
he's out of hits then all of a sudden he
goes to the next one like wait a minute
i know this song
not three times on the ceiling if you
want
me twice on the pipe
right everybody going nuts then he had
another hit after that i'm like god damn
this guy's got a lot of hits
then he got into a drum battle this
drummer
and i'd have to give the nod to tony
and then rickles comes out it was just
amazing just seeing an icon
you know tuxedo the whole old school
thing guy opened up for sinatra
underrated going to go into a casino
to see a legend this is what i realized
uh
this is a very blanket statement but i'm
sort of the king of this
legends play casinos hacks go to cruise
ships
[Music]
is that bad i'm just saying you know
they give you a certain amount of time
to make it in this business
and if you don't they just they just put
you out to see
you know and that's not 100 true there's
some there's some good guys doing
uh but you know what i'm [ __ ] talking
about i told you this story i did a
cruise ship one time i worked with like
a juggler
and uh and the guy hosting it i swear to
god was like
a real-life guy smiley that was that
story i told you
what they told me it was going to be a
young crowd because i was like i don't
think my act is going to work on a
cruise ship this is like 10 11 years ago
they're like no no it's this young this
young with a young hip
cruise liner thing right so i show up
it's a bunch of old people
and the guy smiley guy goes out there
this is how old they were he went out
and he opens with if you're happy and
you know it clap your hands and they did
it
and at that point i was like oh my god i
am going to [ __ ] eat my balls and i
did
it wasn't easy because we were rolling
over the waves it's kind of tricky to
get that second ball in my mouth but i
did
seven minutes into my set [ __ ]
munched them both
captain wrote a letter to the agency oh
god why didn't i ever get a copy of that
said i was offensive to uh
all races the handicapped
i forget what else he said i don't know
nothing i said was
as was as offensive as the [ __ ] food
they were serving on that goddamn boat
oh my god you never saw so many fat
[ __ ] in your life i swear to god if one
of those cruise ships ever goes down
you know has there ever been like an
obese shark
they eat whales too you know what fat
people must be
for sharks just because they don't you
know we're not part of their diet
we just sort of accidentally like we got
to be like remember those big pink
snowballs
those mushrooms they had mushrooms in
the middle and then they had i don't
know what the [ __ ] was
i never had the balls to eat one the
only reason was because it was
marshmallow i always thought marshmallow
was disgusting
i remember fluff peanut butter and fluff
another
that toxic horseshit i actually grew up
right at the tail end
of of just feeding kids
absolute poison
like now they feed poison but it's sort
of disguised you have no idea
because they'll write oh packed with
protein or you know
nutritious [ __ ] you know that somehow
they'll put
put like those words in there they try
and camouflage it but back then
it was just straight up like you know it
was just poison
fluff another the [ __ ] is that i don't
know it's a bunch of white [ __ ] with a
bunch of sugar in you mix it up with
peanut butter all right
will that shut him up uh
all right what am i talking about we're
talking about fat people going overboard
any fat listeners you ever going on a
cruise and just think like wow
if this goes oh well wait a minute would
you float more
if you're fat the big thing is you'd
have to relax
but the problem is is like
you know if you're wearing like a fat
person like uh
like wetsuit you know you're just
covering yourself all up when you're
laying on your back in the ocean
you know the water that's been absorbed
in your bathing suit is gonna be coming
down in your face so you're gonna sort
of be like waterboarding yourself
you know so maybe you gotta roll over on
your stomach
no but then the rolls in your neck are
kind of holding your face in the water
it's
it's a rough deal um
has ever been a fat navy seal i don't
think that has
all right i'm sorry i'm sorry people i i
this is why i do these monday morning
when the brain is fresh i'm just
attacking [ __ ] people who can't
defend themselves
or stop eating um all right
here's something for you oh this is just
choppy as hell
i gotta recommend something uh somebody
recommended to me
told me to go see uh that dave grohl
documentary on soundcity
you can actually go to his website i
wish i had that up there just look up
dave gross sound city you can download
it for 12 bucks
and it's worth every goddamn penny it's
about this studio uh
sound city well basically
i would say maybe 40 it seemed of every
[ __ ] awesome album you've ever
downloaded
or ever wanted to get over the last 40
years was made
um in this studio and uh
dave grohl actually bought the sound
board when it was going out of business
he bought the sound board so that kind
of starts it off
and when you watch it this isn't really
a spoiler alert the whole time they're
interviewing him he's sitting in this
old school van
and i was sitting at going is that a one
of those old ford vans
the original like the the uh ecoliner is
that how you say it the early 60s
i hate how like pedophiles ruined vance
you know what i mean i know if it was
pedophiles or date rapists
but like vans in the in the 60s
if you look at them they're not that bad
they're actually kind of adorable
i'll i'll bring a picture up there like
you know the ford eco line look at that
big
big [ __ ] eyes looked like it needed
some sleep
you know and they were so tiny and you
could just see
you you couldn't do anything in them
people could just see you could see
almost right through the [ __ ] thing
um in the 70s they became creepy
that's when they they started you know
putting carpet on the floors and the
ceiling of them and they had these
crazy sort of acid
murals on the side of them and guys with
hairy chests and mustaches started
driving them around
just somewhere it just became the big
jizz mobile you know
and the skanks liked them i wish i was
around when vans were cool
you know actually i was when i was a kid
i used to think custom vans were the
[ __ ]
i used to think why don't my parents
have a custom van
remember that when you wanted your
parents to be cool why can't he get a
corvette oh i don't know because
there's [ __ ] six kids where the hell
am i gonna stick you
that's when you know your dad's [ __ ]
around and your mom comes home with the
two-seater
[ __ ] the family i'm going out tonight um
all right bill how do you tell a girl
she sucks in bed
um hey bill how do you tell a girl she
sucks in bed without hurting her
feelings or making her
embarrassed is it okay to give pointers
in the bedroom or would you make or
would it make
that make me look like a dick help me
out bill
go [ __ ] yourself um all right the first
half
there's no way to tell a girl she sucks
in bed there's no way for a woman to
tell a guy
he sucks in bed without hurting the
feelings all right
let's be politically correct there's no
way for a guy to tell another guy
if they live in an alternative lifestyle
2013.
no one wants to hear that um
well this is what i would do
you can't just make somebody good in bed
the potential has to be there there has
to be a certain
god-given talent you know what i mean
i mean some women they they reach for
your package like
they're grabbing something out of the
cupboard you know what i mean there's
just no
it's you know what's funny about women
being bad in bed is there's not a lot
of um there's not a lot of story
i think guys not knowing what they're
doing is is
pretty well documented and guilty is
charged
guilty is charged you know but um
it's a definitely a two-way street what
i would do is
if you feel she has potential
rather than give her pointers like hey
listen you're doing a great job in there
it's a couple things like make some
halftime adjustments maybe you could do
that like stop halfway through [ __ ]
you know have her run into the bathroom
and as you run in somebody interviews
you
yeah well you know the first half hour
is pretty good there's definitely some
things we could do better
uh you know my balls are kind of lonely
and uh you know she's gotta
you know she doesn't have a good rhythm
we're gonna try to work on our rhythm in
the uh second half all right yeah go
[ __ ] yourself you know runs back in
um i would suggest rather than okay
definitely don't tell if she sucks
do not give pointers i would the key
word here is guiding
guiding and informative moaning
i would say would be
the uh the most user-friendly
way to protect this girl's feelings it
is
that's what you have to do um i need
more information do you feel she's aware
how does she suck in bed like i said is
she grabbing your dick like she's
you know reaching into a mailbox to see
what the [ __ ] in there or
is she just shy you got to help me out
here i i don't know um
you know that that's what i would do
i would i would guide her and by guide
her i don't mean
pushing her head down guiding
no forcing none of that type of stuff
and uh and then where you got to be
simon cowell
is um don't give her any um
sympathetic moans when she starts
picking up that
the moans you know you know don't give
her any sympathy once
if it ain't doing it for you don't give
her
yeah don't do that just dead silence
okay she has to know it's she it's it's
not working
i don't know what to tell you dude i
know i told this story before i hooked
up with this girl one time
and we were having sex doggy style and
you know when i come forward you're
supposed to back in
you know like we're clapping
uh with crutches
is that a uh was that a [ __ ] is that
one of those dances with wolves names
clapping with crotches sorry hacky joke
um
yeah no what she was doing when i went
back she went back when i went forward
she went forward so i was in her but
there was no friction so i was starting
to have a performance problem before i
ever so gently put one hand on her hip
and the other on the back of her neck
and just sort of stopped her
went back and then pulled her but it
still didn't work it was like not only
does she not know how to do it she was i
think
almost as tall as i was you know
so doggy style you know they got to have
kind of like you know
you can get a little too high there you
know without getting too graphic so i
was already dealing with that
you know um i don't know
beautiful girl though all right um
unexpected pregnancy oh jesus these are
rough this week
unexpected pregnancy bill absolutely
love the podcast and the stand up
you like a skinny louis ck or conversey
louis ck is like a fat bill but i really
wish i didn't read that
uh um anyway not sure
now i get dragged into it uh and i'm not
exactly skinny anymore
i've been having i've been enjoying the
high life lately
miller um anyway to business i'm a 24
year old guy
from sydney australia who's run up
against a big problem
last november i lost a well-paying job
due to an
anxiety disorder i've developed over the
years
i've sought out treatment been through
therapy had all sorts of diets and
breathing exercises and although
recently it's been much more manageable
it's unfortunate it unfortunately wasn't
enough to hold
on to my high pressure job you know what
dude
it was probably the job granted i have
no medical background whatsoever but i
really don't you know when you have to
like
eat a kumquat and start going
just so you can [ __ ] go to work hello
oh nia how are you sorry i just saw the
door open
um the lovely nia everybody
are you busy okay um
oh okay all righty
i'll see ya
okay um
yeah dude when you have to [ __ ] do
[ __ ] like that just to go to work it's
probably the job
and considering you developed it over
the years let me guess was it as you got
this [ __ ] high-pressure job
i don't know so anyways i'm uh currently
i'm looking
for a more low-key job anyways three
days after i'm let go
i get a call from a friend i'd had
drunken unprotected
sex with the only reason why i went back
to our house
was that our house was within walking
distance from the pub
we share a bed and nature takes its
course
oh my god it was a core it was of course
a risk
and like any idiot male i just assumed
nothing would happen
turns out i'm going to be a dad come
august after a mere
one sexual indiscretion i've known this
woman for over
three years she's successful smart witty
and we get on really
well i'll be getting on really well uh
she is
sorry there was a big space in a new
paragraph i'm not that dumb people
please
please still believe in me um she's been
up up until now
childless and you can understand her
reasonings for wanting to keep the spawn
she expects me to play an active role in
the parenting game
and to be honest that's something i am
wholeheartedly prepared to do
that's so [ __ ] up they like make the
decision i mean because it is their body
they have to go through the procedure
but it's just really
you're really just uh you're just a
[ __ ]
jizz host that's really all we are um we
were both
irresponsible we should both have to
pick up the pieces and work [ __ ] out
here's the problem she wants me to move
in with her [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that before i read
any more of this [ __ ] that
anyways in fact she's demanded i moved
in with her
uh double [ __ ] that she's making demands
go [ __ ] yourself all right i wish you
did that earlier i wouldn't have been
situated um i can't help thinking that
this arrangement would descend
very quickly into mutual resentment and
unhappiness and would eventually be a
detrimental environment for the kid
abso-fucking-lootly
i'd live with friends in the past and if
a dirty kitchen can cause
irritation i don't know how [ __ ]
drooling a [ __ ] drooling screaming
baby will fly under the radar
i want to move somewhere close by so i
can share their parenting duties
but i don't see how moving in is a
better solution
she is also asking for financial support
to the tune of
half which the [ __ ] i've spelt out
above shirley makes this impossible
um she's tit deep in an already
blossomed career
and i'm doing my best to stay away from
the dole or as americans say welfare
uh so i'm asking advice on two things
how do i really
how do i relay my moving in doubts to a
hormonal pregnant woman without hurting
her feelings
or making her feel like she has to go go
at it alone
and how can i spell it out to her that i
won't be able to be there for the baby
financially in the way she wants
jesus christ dude what else and how do
you [ __ ]
jump to the moon uh by the way when she
told me
about the pregnancy and oh jesus arrived
fully formed in my mouth
go [ __ ] yourself [ __ ] um
you just have to have an adult
conversation with her just be like look
who's kid and who we're not in love with
one another
you're not my soul mate i'm not your
soul mate but we're both adults and we
did this so we have to take
responsibility
okay um
i would still like to meet my soul mate
and i imagine you would too
and we're not going to be able to do
that if we're if we're
basically pretending to be a couple
which we're not
we're not okay uh just look at the baby
like we both we it's like a time share
condo
[Music]
sorry um no just to tell you
you're not gonna move in i'm not moving
in with you i'm going to support you 100
with the baby 100 but i'm not moving in
and when she says why just be like
because i'm not in love with you we're
not we're not getting married we
screwed up and now we're doing the right
thing
but um yeah i'm not moving in and what's
she gonna do grab you by the throat make
you move in no
[ __ ] this and the fact that she's making
these demands she wants half of your
money well
this is the deal dude you knocked a girl
up and now you got a [ __ ]
you got a kid coming so you got to go
make some money
all right and you do have to support the
kid
um this is one of these [ __ ] up things
if she's got a great career why does she
need half of your salary
you know what i mean if you had a great
career she wouldn't even [ __ ] work
why don't you say this all right how
about this why don't i be mr mom i'll
stay home with the kid and you go out
and work and you support me i'll i'll
wear a [ __ ] apron
have at it lady go put on your nancy
reagan power suit and [ __ ] have at it
yeah dude look
what what do you
i know you got the double whammy here i
this i wouldn't
i wouldn't do a double header here
although the conversation might go in
that direction but i would definitely
not tell her that
i'm i'm moving in with her there's
there's no [ __ ] way there's no way
that that's happening
all right there's no way that that's
happening
um because i'm not in love with you and
let her hem let her haul let her cry let
her scream let her throw [ __ ] let her do
whatever the [ __ ] she wants to do
yeah you're not moving in with her sir
all right
don't do it don't go to bed with a price
on your head
no don't do it um sorry beretta
don't [ __ ] do it all right and then
as far as like
uh you know
supporting your kid you got to do it you
got to give her the money
you can't have this kid he's in an
unbelievably unfortunate
situation you have to make the best of
it and
you guys have to be friends and that's
another reason for not moving in
you know what are you gonna sleep in the
same bed
like you're married like you love each
and you can't [ __ ] do it
so um
i don't know but as far as the money
thing yeah you got to go out and start
making some money and if you have to
sleep on a [ __ ] futon or whatever
believe me that's going to be better
than having you know some 18 year old
kid someday
who uh had a [ __ ] childhood because of
you and then you got to deal with that
and then try and put the pieces together
when you're on your [ __ ]
bed you don't do that either but uh as
far as moving and [ __ ] that
move close by and uh that's it
it's not up for discussion okay and she
can make all the [ __ ] demands she
wants to
demands dope you made up you
she made a mistake too the [ __ ] she'd
make a demands out of you for
furthermore why the [ __ ] you why why you
worried about it
all right she can't force you to move in
so [ __ ] her
all right with the condom next time sir
all right legalzoom.com
everybody legalzoom.com are you waiting
for the perfect time to start your dream
business
it's now legalzoom the official sponsor
of the national start your business
month
wants you to get it started right you
got to protect yourself for everybody
so whether you're setting up an llc an s
corp a sole proprietorship
or a non-profit legal zoom takes care of
you
from start to finish their award-winning
service was developed by the best legal
minds in the country
and every business gets personalized
attention that's why over ninety percent
of legalzoom customers would recommend
the service to their family
you'll be in good company over two dozen
companies
on the inc 500 list were started through
legalzoom
these guys got the credits here or what
uh it's national start your business
month so start your business right now
at legalzoom.com
um legalzoom is not a law firm and
provides self-help services at your
specific direction so if you have
questions
ask them and they will answer them but
there's so much more now every llc and
incorporation package includes easy to
use business accounting software
a 269 value for absolutely free
be sure to enter bur bur b-u-r-r in the
referral box at checkout
start your business protect your family
and safeguard your assets
at legalzoom.com today
um is that it
is that it for the i think that's it for
the ad stuff here's something i saw i
was trying to
get something to talk about on the
podcast here
um so i looked up the drudge report
because i always say this is like
something that people look at
and they were talking about newt
gingrich's ex-wife
unloads on camera network debates the
ethics of airing
what she said about her former husband
before the south carolina primary
okay and you guys know like when i talk
about hockey and you have no idea what
i'm talking about
this this is my version of it south
carolina primary for what
what is newt gingrich running for mayor
of south carolina
or senator is that what it'd be i i
don't pay attention to this [ __ ]
um so anyways i guess his his marlene
gingrich
has said she could end her ex-husband's
career with a single interview
oh hell hath no fury just take the
[ __ ] alimony
what did he oh didn't he didn't he do
something wasn't she sick in the
hospital and he kind of tagged somebody
else
why do you think he could get away with
it with that giant head of his
um anyways earlier this week she sat
before abc news cameras
she spoke to abc news reporter brian
ross for two hours and her explosive
revelations are set to rock the trial
what trial
i don't [ __ ] know it's just another
ex-wife just going absolutely
why why would you do that
aren't you biting the hand that feeds as
much as you hate this guy and he was
probably a piece of [ __ ]
to you i mean you're really going to
affect his ability
if he doesn't win that political office
how can he pay for your mercedes with
all that [ __ ] hush money
all the bribe money he's going to get
you know
how can how are you going to afford to
get your hair and nails did
every [ __ ] two weeks you know if he
doesn't have a job where he gets to look
the other way is people poor [ __ ] in the
water supply
for god's sakes woman have you thought
this through
i don't [ __ ] know all right what are
we doing here is that is that all the
advertising i got to make sure i didn't
miss any of the [ __ ] advertising they
always end up flipping out at me
oh you know he's supposed to read it and
you didn't read it you know what's going
on with that
couldn't you read it earlier
i think that was it all right that was
it for the other than the amazon stuff
when i say that every week so you know
where am i in the podcast right now 46
[ __ ] minutes in look at me
wheezing across the [ __ ] finish line
this week
you know what i actually had a great
week really bill well it hasn't
translated into a great podcast you
unfunny content all right i know
i know it's been a little lackluster
little [ __ ] lackluster um
dear billiam i know this is last minute
i didn't even tell you guys why i had a
great week i went out and i did a bunch
of stand up and this was like
four things that i've been working on
meticulously crafting in front of taurus
down at the comedy store
and uh i suddenly i
figured out a through line where it all
connected
made that [ __ ] when people say you know
you don't know how to write a script
just start writing a bunch of themes
just write little vignettes and then
somehow they all stick together which
never [ __ ] works
um that's like you're trying to build a
house just start hammering [ __ ]
um but it actually worked out with the
stand-up thing
i have a nice through line i have a new
chunk of [ __ ] that i've strung together
like some cheesy thing with a bunch of
beads
and some native person that was
supplanted through genocide is now
sitting on the [ __ ] curb about now
was it honolulu is that what i saw them
um
supplanted is that a word relocated
valentine's day advice billy boy
dearest billiam i know this is last
minute
i had a question about valentine's day i
am a single guy in my mid-20s
rejoice
dude i'm going to tell you right now if
you're a single guy in your mid-20s
and you live in america and you're
living on your own
please drop to your knees
and and thank whatever god you pray to
every day because you're never going to
be freer in your life
i know you probably got student loans
and blah blah blah the stress and all
that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that okay you're never gonna be
freer
in your life go get
three-year supplies of condoms
okay and bang away my friend
maybe you don't need to do it for three
years maybe you're one of those guys for
only three weeks but you need to get it
out of your system
all right he says i never really had a
girlfriend for whatever reason oh
jesus christ all right we're going a
whole other other way truth be told my
friends
could name numerous reasons why i don't
have a girlfriend
but that's an entirely different issue
well jesus christ there's a [ __ ] can
of worms
they can you don't seem defensive or
argumentative
so i don't know if it's an anger issue
that look i'm so sick of trying to be
[ __ ] hannibal lecter here
trying to guess what your shoes look
like with with the way you write you
know
all right i'm just gonna read the rest
of this [ __ ] uh as of right now i am
currently sleeping with three girls
off oh so you're [ __ ] you're knocking
it out i thought you'd like never had a
girlfriend
like and you like never banged anybody
all right my fault
all right dude go [ __ ] yourself you're a
guy in your mid-20s and you're [ __ ]
three girls right now and i'm this you
need advice
uh keep doing what you're doing um
anyways depending on what day of the
week it is and how much i've drank
okay that depends on how many girls he's
banging uh i've never lied to anything
any of any of them
about where our relationship is going
and although they never met each other
each of them has an idea that i'm seeing
other girls
it's kind of a don't ask don't tell
policy
uh yeah dude and you got to come with
that you know you can open with that
you know what are you doing i'm dating
i'm playing the field
how many people are you dating right now
a couple of people kind of seeing
just having a good time well i don't do
stuff like that well there's the door
sweetheart
then they'll respect like that the
honesty of that
some won't some will actually have
self-esteem and walked out but a lot of
them they'll hang around
eventually they get tired their neck
gets weak and they'll fall right in your
[ __ ] dick
um birthdays and christmas are always a
piece of cake
because all that requires a quick text
or a phone call
or at the very most drinks at the bar
but valentine's day is tricky
our dates consist of bar hopping and
drunk sex
so flowers and a nice dinner would
completely send the wrong message
dude you selfish [ __ ] are you asking me
how to keep banging these three chicks
while getting through valentine's day
why don't you just look at the
valentine's day like that's your [ __ ]
getting all-star break
just take three days off the day before
the day after and the day of
just say uh what are you doing for
valentine's day
i'm uh i'm gonna be uh
jesus where are you gonna be i don't i
don't have a good one for that one
all right you know what i just put
myself in your shoes and i understand
your problem now
he said i got to a little bit of trouble
last year when one of the girls texted
me and said
you know every girl likes flowers on
valentine's day
he said i knew my response couldn't be
yeah but if i get you flowers then i
have to get
flowers for all the other girls so i
just pushed out and responded yeah well
oh dude you shouldn't responded at all
you know every girl likes to give
flowers on valentine's day isn't that
funny
and that has nothing to do with most
likely her
having any sort of feelings towards you
it's just the [ __ ] next to her and the
other cubicle probably got some you know
another girl on there [ __ ] whatever
the [ __ ] you want to call it
some guy broke my balls this week was
[ __ ] hilarious he was trashing me
saying come off as a pompous ass because
i always talk about
anybody who doesn't do comedy works in a
cubicle
you know and for some reason he decided
to take that seriously and tell me that
he actually works at the un
and travels all around the world
[Music]
[Laughter]
if that's actually true sir how why
don't you just get on with doing that
you work at the u.n
and you travel all over the world why
would you give a [ __ ]
what some absolute jackass is saying on
a [ __ ] podcast
how insecure are you your insecurities
probably a great thing because that's
probably the thing that drove you
to be at the u.n where you travel all
around the world
you know what sir good for you that's
awesome
i hope working at the un and traveling
all around the world
fills you up some point where it fills
you up high enough
where you don't have to respond to a
silly joke on some dumbass podcast
um i travel all around the world
um you know what that's actually a great
[ __ ] job
do you feel like you get anything done
you know do you sit there wearing that
headpiece next to that guy who's wearing
the water buffalo hat
doing that [ __ ] and you're sitting there
trying to talk to him about how you can
sell your ritz crackers to their country
is that what you're doing when you're
traveling all around the world i travel
all around the world
[Laughter]
[Music]
i can just see you on the plane with
your [ __ ] dress socks on you have a
dash
[ __ ] oh just sitting there what movies
am i going to watch
on this flight as i travel all around
the world
um anyways you know something sir you
had you you had the james bond job
and then you [ __ ] you played yourself
i don't know why you did that why would
you [ __ ]
that's like me responding to people on
twitter why would i do it i should
pretend like i have better things to do
um anyways i want to keep seeing all
these girls back to this guy
but this but at the same time i don't
want any broken hearts on valentine's
day
oh dude you know what go i think i don't
unders what is your problem here
dude are you like a gemini it's like
you're this [ __ ] lady killer then
also you're kind of like you know i
don't want to hurt anybody should i get
her some jam jams
i i can't even i won't talk to the
[ __ ] un guy what the hell was going
on here again
valentine's day got a little trouble
last year well listen you're
anticipating trouble didn't you learn
anything from last year
you know every girl likes flowers on
valentine's day
um what would i write back
i know what my response would be the
second i read that if it was just some
girl i was banging and then they wrote
that i would get this awful feeling in
my
stomach and i would
i would read it and as i got that awful
feeling i'd go yeez
and make that noise you know that thing
like when you're just banging a girl and
then all of a sudden she just [ __ ]
makes that comment
you know you think she's on the same
page as you when she just makes that
comment
you know i was thinking about you today
you just feel that feeling in your
stomach
oh yeah well uh don't
that's the [ __ ] worst
uh you gotta be one and done but one and
done is scary
just gotta be honest i don't know if
some girls what would i say you know
every girl likes flowers on valentine's
day
um what would i text back yeah you know
that's what i heard
you know what i don't you know what i
shouldn't give you [ __ ] i don't have a
good response to that
well maybe someday you'll meet a guy who
wants to give you some
you want to get drunk and [ __ ] um yeah i
got nothing
and you can't ignore it
you know what i would have done i would
have ignored the text and i would have
called her
but a good three hours later three four
hours three hours later that's a good
one you call her you ignore that text
and you call
and she goes hello and like hey what's
going on
what are you doing tonight i got no
plans valentine's day what are you doing
and you just started with that
and then she well what are you out of
there and she'll be seeing if you're
going to take it some romantic
you know direction and you don't
you just keep it in the [ __ ] buddy well
i figured we'd go down to uh meat
hammers or whatever
whatever the [ __ ] you call it we go down
to uh
take it in the face have a couple
pictures of beer and uh see what happens
dude you know what you're you're it
seems to me you're not just [ __ ]
these girls you're actually having like
these mini relationships with them
you know the the key to having a [ __ ]
buddy is
is the time between [ __ ] them
and i don't give a [ __ ] how much a woman
says that she can
handle it most of them can't most of
them can't if you're [ __ ] coming over
there
and you and just eventually they're
gonna get feelings
they're more i don't know if they're
more mature or if it's a defect it's
just
i just respect the fact that that's how
they're wired so
you if you have a [ __ ] buddy okay let's
just do the math
okay now now february is a very short
month here so let's just say right out
of the gate you [ __ ] on february 2nd
all right you shouldn't come around
again till at least the 17th
and grant you [ __ ] and you leave
fnl you [ __ ] him and then you leave
you don't bang her on the second you
bang around the second and then you bang
her on the seventh
you're in a [ __ ] relationship in
their world
you know unless
you literally the second you have an
orgasm
as you're coming you're scooping up your
clothes and you walk out like half naked
then you're just bizarre
which is another good way to keep him at
bay and why don't i just read the rest
of this and see what it what his
question is here he says i want to keep
seeing all these girls but at the same
time i don't want to break i don't want
any broken hearts on valentine's day
yeah you want to keep [ __ ] all of
them
no dude what you have to have you have
to have a revolving door
you have to have a stable of women if
you're going to live this life or you
have to give in to [ __ ] rubbing one
out
all right but you can't be a
relationship guy with three different
women because you are going to end up
hurting them so what you have to
constantly be doing you got to be like a
college coach
all right every year you lose some top
prospects but you're out there
recruiting
okay so you so you maintain
but it's never ending it's [ __ ]
exhausting
but if that's the game you want to play
that's what you have to do so
that girl who says you know every girl
likes flowers on valentine's day
right there you put her on waivers okay
for uh for a
[ __ ] piece of ass to be named later
you got
you gotta get rid of her okay
and you gotta look go back and analyze
what the [ __ ] you did wrong
that she felt it was okay for her to
text you because you [ __ ] up that
right there shows that you [ __ ] up
that she felt that she could send that
to you if you think you're just [ __ ]
buddies
all right so anyways he continues he
says i know that
like it or not this [ __ ] is important to
women if i take one girl
out i'm playing favorites and setting a
bad precedent
plus if she does that check in [ __ ] on
facebook i'm completely [ __ ]
yeah dude you're doing dirtbag [ __ ] if
you're a single guy and something could
happen
that [ __ ] you on facebook you're
leading these girls on
anyways he says if i take none of them
out or do nothing i have three irritable
ladies on my hand
dude are you going to marry any of them
no
well then let them go why don't you have
the balls to do that
you know when a team halfway through the
season just realized dude we ain't
winning this [ __ ]
just pull up [ __ ] marlins just get
rid of everybody
and then your fan base is your dick and
they're gonna he's gonna be pissed for a
while
um but then you build it back up again
build it back up again you know
i don't know look dude if you want to be
in a [ __ ] relationship you know
there's other ways about going about it
than doing this but you're trying to
have your cake and eat it
um dude you you got three women right
now you're banging three different women
where's your confidence you know what
you're doing
all right dump two keep one at bay
and then get two more then dump the
other one and get the other one just
you don't even dump them you just phase
them out phase them out
but the new recruits that you get in you
got to be straight up honest with them
you know unless you actually feel
feelings if you're feeling no feelings
you know don't keep coming back [ __ ]
them unless you know you get that 15-day
you [ __ ] him on the second you [ __ ] him
on the 17th
then you're into march and then banger
on like the 11th
all right and even then they can't catch
feelings doing that
but before you know it you know
that's like 14 15 days out of the year
taking up
where you got to bang somebody this is
such this is this is really should be
eye opening to women that i'm actually
saying this is really uh
this is really awful that i'm speaking
this out loud
um he says in a perfect world i'll take
all of them out at once and have the
foursome i've been chasing after my
entire life but we don't always get what
we want any advice from the lovely nia
would be much appreciated as well love
the podcast go [ __ ] yourself
uh yeah she probably wouldn't have been
as
understanding as i was even though i
gave you a lot of [ __ ]
um anyways that's the podcast for this
week
er buddy um
i don't i don't have any i'm [ __ ]
tapped out
i'm tapped out it's been [ __ ] three
days under a truck
not really doing anything just watching
titus do
the whole [ __ ] thing um anyways uh
thanks to christopher titus
for uh helping me with the breaks of my
truck thanks to everybody who's been uh
continuing to download my special which
is uh
tremendous and uh if you want to help
out somebody uh
or just check out something great uh
please check out uh sound city the new
dave grohl
um documentary i cannot recommend it
highly enough
uh it's 12 bucks off his website money
well spent
and uh when that [ __ ] comes out on dvd
i'm gonna buy it
i like having the gold behind my money i
don't like downloading [ __ ] and then
just
you know then it's just on this thing
and then this thing dies and then that
thing [ __ ] crashes and then i don't
have it anymore
you know what i mean i don't like that
[ __ ] all right i'm rambling go [ __ ]
yourselves
i'll talk to you next week and uh oh i
know why there's nothing to talk about
football's over
[ __ ] over
[Music]
it
uh
[Music]
stuff
you